If you're cold calling and not sending leads in advance,
so the built-in trust isn't there,
how would you go about building enough trust
on the first call when the I need to think about it
comes up at the end of the call?
So to make sure everyone understands this question guys,
he's talking about like, if you wanna start cold calling
without doing the leads in advance,
which is totally doable, right?
I mean, people do it all the time.
I think that it can be done.
I wouldn't recommend it.
If you're new, I wouldn't recommend it.
Some of you guys might be looking at, go, well,
if I do that, then I could save a little bit of money.
It's like, it's so much easier with leads
that I don't recommend it, right?
However, if you decide,
cause I know Shane's gone pretty far
and he's 10,000 a month plus.
He knows what he's doing.
Maybe he wants to just kind of try his hand in it.
That Shane, it's simple is I'm using,
I'm selling through my other customers.
I'm showing, I'm over showing examples.
I'm using everything I say is not what I say.
It's what Joe, my duct cleaning client said.
It's what Marianne, my tow truck client said.
We call it selling through the neighbors, right?
And I'm referring over and over and over.
You know, anything they have, any question,
you gotta use the neighbors.
You gotta use your business owners.
That's it, you have to.
You're gonna have to show a lot of examples.
That's gonna be the trust, right?
When you give leads in advance,
that's how you overcome the objection of trust.
But if you don't have leads in advance,
then you have to use other means.
And so I would say selling through your customers,
using stories, using screenshots of text messages,
pulling up call rail and showing them,
hey, here's what this guy did.
Here's how many leads he got.
That's basically the only way
you're gonna be able to do it.